Tình hình là tự sướng mai tôi để remix ạ
vậy sợ gì à à
anh alo
Anh ở hình ở từ trước ngày tôi đến mạch
sạc
Xin
chào các bạn
Alo alo alo
ở nhà tranh thủ Tâm sự tí tránh thổ tâm
sự về Hồng đi
Ừ cái này là về rồi
Anh Đức Tin
Em không biết thì mấy ông quan điểm thế
nào nhớ tao về về
các hướng ở tôi tôi từng là một người
rất là mấy tín tìm hiểu khá nhiều về tâm
linh lẫn đã bói những cả Nói chung là
khi các cung hoàng đạo ở hai vân vân
nhiều người thích nghe mình vấn đề đấy
mà cái nào của đấy chỗ tìm hiểu
Ô kìa tôi cảm thấy là đa số đa số thì là
lợi dụng mà tâm lý học nhiều hơn là thực
sự là cảm nhận được có một cái gì đó
Ừ tôi không phủ nhận là việc là tôi vẫn
tin là có thế giới bên kia cũng như là
linh hồn ai cái sự Vân Vân có nhưng mà
tôi
Em Không Tin tuyệt đối vào bất kỳ cái á
một cái gì lên màn hình bói hay là số
phận mình do do mình sinh ra Ví dụ Giả
sử nhé Để tự như ông sinh ra một cái giờ
người ta bảo là giờ đấy ông sẽ rất là do
ngày Đúng rồi đấy Đúng ngày này ông sẽ
rất là giàu thế ông sẽ vui chơi thoải
mái tự nhiên tiền rơi xuống Nếu được thế
thì nữa cuộc sống của ông chẳng cần có
gì Cố gắng ạ đúng loạn đấy Tất cả những
cái người mà sinh ra đúng rồi cái giờ
đấy cùng ông tất cả không giàu quá Tôi
không tin mấy cái vớ vẩn đấy đúng ạ Có
làm cái có ăn không ạ thì
Ừ thì giờ thế nên À thì nên là mình là
mình sẽ mình theo có điểm về tử vi hay
bất kỳ cái bói gì cả tôi chẳng tin tự
nhiên là nếu mà người ta khuyên mình một
cái gì đó là sự là năm nay có vấn đề gì
đó cần đề phòng Vân thiếu sẵn tính tôi
sẽ đề phòng cẩn thận ngồi cũng sẽ không
Không đến nỗi không tin rồi cứ thế mà
làm tôi sẽ giờ à cẩn thận Nhưng mà còn
làm việc là người ta khuyên giả sử
khuyên nhé Nó kia
ông không hợp với bạn đấy đâu sẽ là cái
thứ tuổi này không hợp thứ không tin vào
bất kỳ của mình rồi đấy
cũng như là nó bảo là thực ra thì bó
toán về cơ bản Thật ra nó khá nói tốt
với tôi Tôi không biết nói mấy ông chưa
em Nói chung nhà về tôi khá tốt đấy là
kiểu kể cả tin hay không thì tôi nghĩ hả
Thì không vẫn được nó bảo ở phía sau tôi
sẽ giàu và tôi không phải tôi có số có
thể giàu như tôi không Ừ cái đấy trả
người ta đọc được tôi hai cái gì đó
nhưng có vẻ nó đúng à
anh cũng như là bảo số tôi có đào hoa Ừ
cũng đúng nếu mà giờ xử so với tất cả
tôi Tôi hẹn hò nhiều hơn cát ông thì
chắc chắn là tội đào hoa hơn mấy ông lấy
đúng nhưng tỷ lệ tỷ lệ thấp tỷ lệ để
thành tỏ tình thành công của tôi cũng
thấp cũng chỉ dưới 10 phần trăm
cũng không biết được mấy ông có thể tán
112 Bạn ăn luôn cái gì lại ông đã 23 năm
rồi tỷ lệ Tôi dưới mươi phần trăm những
điều dễ hiểu là nó cũng không được tính
cho đào hoa lắm
em hẹn tiếp theo thì vì tôi nghĩ tôi
nghĩ là cái đức tin này khá nhiều cũng
như là tôi hồi trước đọc khá nhiều cái
chuyện chuyện thần thoại thôi Nó là kiểu
dạng là con người mình có thể chống lại
được thấy nhiên hay chống lại được ở
thậm chí cả thần linh hôm bữa mày Ông
đọc cái chuyện kiểu như thế chưa
nghe tội càng tin mà về học phí thon ra
có việc làm không anh ấy ông học cái gì
là làm việc được
Ừ ông đừng có bi quan học học cái gì
không không kiếm việc
ờ ờ
du lịch có ma không Anh I Do ca về đối
với tôi con điểm thôi
thiên về khoa học nhiều hơn đấy Tôi
không tin nhưng mà tôi vẫn
khoa học nó không mở phủ nhận được không
có người ngoài tinh hay không có thế
giới tâm linh nhá Nó không được phủ nhận
được đấy khoa học nó sinh ra cốt để cho
con người mình bớt tin vớ vẩn và mình sẽ
phải giải thích được những cái gì đó
đúng như là có rất nhiều cái nó vẫn còn
là giả thuyết và có rất nhiều cái gì
chứng minh được rồi nhưng mà biết được
đâu Được đấy tầng 10 năm nữa để lại lại
chứng minh được nó sai thì thì dao khoa
học nó đưa rất nhiều giả thuyết và giả
thuyết là mà không có một cái gì bác bỏ
được nó thì giả thuyết đấy tạm cho là
đúng thời điểm hiện tại đấy thế này là
có cái hay như thế nghĩa chúng ta có thể
tạm tin giả thuyết Bây giờ em ạ là ví dụ
là con người là là độc nhất hai ra gió
Nhưng mà thực ra là
ai cũng có thể có người bảo là có ma Hạ
Tôi thường anh ấy không giống ma tôi
linh hồn hạn chế tránh tự ma không hay
lắm
Ừ tôi từng nghe vụ đấy đã
người kia người người có bên kia sẽ
không thích gọi là mà
linh hồn
anh nói chung là tiếp theo là nhắc đến
linh hồn đấy thì tội định nói về cái vụ
cơ thể con người thật phi thường dùng
cái tiêu đề như thế này bởi vì à
vì vậy vì nó liên hoan Đức tin khá nhiều
khi đôi khi chúng ta từ một cái bàn tay
trắng không ạ chúng ta thể làm được rất
nhiều thứ nghĩa là chúng tập tin vào
điều đấy ngẫu nhiên là kéo
Ê mày ông cứ thấy điện hình là có những
người tin một cách mù quáng người đó làm
được nhiều cái cực Kể cả đánh bom Tự tử
nhưng mà đại khái là tin mà cái gì ở
người làm được rất nhiều thứ kể cả vượt
qua được ung thư gì đó
có ma và Cái quan trọng là thôi mà tôi
Họ đã cất đi Tôi từng nói rồi đó là mấy
ông phải đánh bại nó cái niềm tin này nó
không phải làm chủ được cái niềm tin này
ông tin là ông sẽ giàu không tin ông sẽ
do
Ừ ông đâu Tí không phải tin điều này đã
ông không phải tin mình là một thằng vô
dụng thì ông sẽ mãi là một thằng vô dụng
thật
à Còn nếu mà thực sự ở công ty đóng giỏi
thì ông sẽ sẽ có sẽ tự tự cho mình cái
cậu kể gọi như thế nào
em tự cho cơ thể mình phát triển còn mua
khi móng tay lâu ngày 11 đứa kém cỏi thì
ông sẽ đang tìm kim hãm chính mình tôi
tôi quan điểm anh như thế ví dụ điển
hình nhá ví dụ nha Tôi hỏi ông một câu
gì đó thì ông thay vì ông ngồi ông nghĩ
trước khi ông ngồi nghĩ nát óc đã rồi
ông có thể Ông vẫn không trả lời được
nhưng mà lúc đấy Ông đã là ông đã gọi là
nghĩ gọi là có phát động rồi không ạ
chẳng qua là có thể hiện tại không không
không trả lời được thôi Bởi vì nó quá
tầm cái gì đó nhưng mà đến vài về sau
tôi lại hỏi ông ấy Có đấy Có thể ông lần
này nó lại nghĩ thêm một lần nữa vẫn có
thể không chở được nhưng mà lần này ông
đã tự dần dần dần mình thông minh hơn tí
tôi tôi bảo đấy nào ông có lúc đấy hơn
tí Anh bảo kiểu tóc tại lúc đầu lại làm
sao tập cực nặng ngoại tập từ đúng ạ
nhưng mua khi mà cũng đã suy nghĩ là ông
kém cỏi ông ngu dốt đồ kiểu ngoại Ông
thằng à hãy dùng từ là thằng thất bại
cái gì đó Vân ấy cũng tự coi ông ý thế
Ừ thì ông lão ông ông sẽ luôn luôn không
cho não hoạt động luôn khi mà tôi hỏi
bất kỳ cái gì ông chưa gì không trả lời
tôi không biết tôi không muốn biết tôi
không thể biết tôi kém cỏi tôi không vừa
thì biết là cái này nó không muốn nghĩ
ko trả lời thì chắc chắn tôi sẽ không
biết mãi chẳng hạn như thế
Ừ thì à cả chí chứ cái ý chí của ông anh
tìm hãm sự phát triển của chính ông chứ
chẳng ai tìm hộ ông cả Không ạ nên là
tôi thấy á
ờ ờ
người gọi là tin vào bản thân mình có
thể là tự kiêu 2 Vân đi ra họ còn học
còn kiểu xả lòng để cho cơ thể mình phát
triển đúng không ạ Con những người làm
gò bó bản thân mình hóa không cho cơ thể
phát triển thì sẽ toàn là người không
không thể phát triển không ạ nên lại sức
mạnh niềm tin tôi nghĩa là rất quan
trọng
anh Tại ông ông ví dụ Giả sử nhà sửa nhé
ờ ờ ông chưa Tán gái ông bảo không mình
không có tán được ai đâu kể cả bạn đấy
chủ động thả thấy không phải có nghĩa
không Bạn ấy không hề thích mình đâu rồi
cùng với gạt đi theo tôi nó thứ tôi cùng
thì cơ hội Trôi mất tiêu rồi Thế không
phải mỗi tán gái trong cuộc sống Ông có
rất nhiều cái nữa cơ hội này đến cơ hội
việc làm với Vân đến ông cứ nghĩ là
không mình không cố gắng để làm điều này
mình kém gọi mình không thể làm được đều
này
bắt đầu với cùng cơ hội vào tay người
khác ngoại
hôm nay là tôi nghĩ là mấy ông nha
và Nếu có thể thì
em có những ông tự ti tôi biết có rất
nhiều Tôi quen rất nhiều ông tự tin ông
ấy giỏi thật nhưng mà Ừ ông ấy tự giới
hạn bản thân mình quá còn tôi là dạy con
người ạ Thực ra nhiều người bảo tôi giỏi
được cái tự tin Thôi tự tin hơn người đó
không mở Thái Minh giỏi ví dụ là sự nhãn
giỏi phải đúng nghĩa là thầy dạy hay dạy
một hẹn một bạn đấy đã hiểu được 34 bạn
ấy bạn ấy từ một cái một đấy bạn sinh ra
được 34 đã làm được ba bốn cái con 21
tôi Tôi phải cố mãi mới hiểu được cái
một cái còn hai quên các thứ xong rồi
còn nhiều lúc gạo Mình còn thằng hiểu
được Hãy soạn thế nhưng tôi chưa rồi
để tôi chữa bao đời luôn đó là coi mình
là là người kém làm người ngu dốt không
không Ừ tôi sẽ luôn củ bạn thân mình để
hiểu
Ê bà nghĩ rằng là Chiều dì bị sẽ hiểu
được Kiểu gì mình sẽ làm được người khác
làm được thì ra là tội không dùng cái
câu người khác làm được mình làm được
hay là người cái gì đó giống nhiều văn
vở ở đâu vậy chỉ đơn giản là tôi không
có tâm người khác như thế nào Tôi muốn
làm cái điều này mà tôi thôi kiểu thôi
đấy thì đại khá tốt muốn làm gì cả Tôi
không không quan tâm người khác có làm
được không Tôi muốn làm được cái nó tới
làm thế đó
Ừ ông ông đừng có tâm người khác nghĩ gì
ông còn trẻ ông cứ thử đã người khác
trước khi trước khi
có những cái kỷ lục thế giới nó ra đời
rõ ra là đầy người không nghĩ là có thể
làm được đấy đúng không ạ những mà những
cái người mà tạo ra kỉ lục Tôi không nói
là mấy ông sẽ tạo một cái kỷ lục gì đó
nó không cần ở vĩ đại thế nhưng mà ý là
trước khi mà có một kỷ lục gì đó rõ là
tất cả mọi người không nghĩ là có thể
làm được đấy nhưng mà có những người
không hề nghĩ không phải nghĩ mà cứ cắm
đầu à đúng ạ Họ nghĩ họ làm được mà nó
cùng họ làm thật ạ
anh giống như kiểu bé ông học học bơi
hay học lái xe cũng thế
anh ở đây xa trả ông nào không biết đi
xe đâu không ạ thì mấy ông đôi mày ông
lên thì mày không phải tin rồi ông sẽ
làm chủ được tay lái không ạ đi được rồi
sẽ đi được người khác bởi vì một phần
Ông thấy hả Bị trước rồi không nghĩ là
cái vị sẽ đi được chứ Nếu mà bây giờ
mình sống cái thời kỳ mà chưa ai đi xe
trước mặt ông bây giờ thì ông cũng nghĩ
là không thể làm cân bằng được cái con
xe đấy Sao ạ Không ạ
anh đúng không cái điểm hay của cái thế
hệ của mình tôi cảm thấy nó 2 điểm là
mình có đầy người đi trước rồi mình một
là mình học hỏi mày đi trước hay là mình
à
cho mình kiểu dạng là mình tự tin vào
bản thân mình đấy
Ừ thì mình sẽ làm được
Ừ đấy là lý do tôi cũng thường anh nói
qua với mấy cái về cái này nhiều và tôi
cũng muốn gần gũi thì mấy ông để mà mày
Ông cảm thấy là tôi thật ra cũng chẳng
có gì ghê gớm cái mà ông hoàn toàn thì
như được tôi và thận chứa sẽ hơn được
tôi tôi rồi đang có nhiều việc quá hay
chưa thôi Nhiều cái cực mà lương và
Lương hấp dẫn
từ hôm trước rồi trò mày ông xem di đi
chưa cái đường link đi đấy Hoàn Lương
hấp dẫn thôi Tôi muốn tôi không hẳn là
tôi muốn nhảy việc đâu nhưng mà nhiều
quá mấy ông kiểu
vợ tôi rồi kéo của
ở cổ họng Khả lên cho người cướp cướp
việc nha
anh nhiều việc quá không có quá nhiều
việc mà uống cưới kiểu không cướp được
cơ không hết
a tiếp theo tự nhiên
á Vừa nãy có một bạn nào đó
bình luận trên trên một cái video mới
đây của tôi bảo là mình có bán kinh
không ạ
Ừ cái này thôi mình chia sẻ lại nhớ nó
hơi buồn cười nhất là chắc chắn là mày
không biết sẽ không được bán kênh để rồi
làm mọi thứ cho vui nhận không ạ thứ hai
đó là
khi tôi thấy buồn cười
vì rõ ràng là kênh của tôi chả có cái gì
cả anh tôi Đúng là có lượng tương tác có
người thật cái gì đó nhưng mà chính vì
Ê mày ông theo dõi là chủ yếu theo dõi
là tôi ý chứ không phải là bất kỳ mèo
khác đây là bây giờ nhớ là sự kênh này
mà giờ danh khác giữa xả nào tôi nghĩ
mày cũng sẽ bị trở dõi thôi cái này ra
ta
khi người ta mua kênh này nó chạy nghĩa
gì cả thật ra mua cái này lập tức cả
lượng người theo dõi hay mọi tương tác
và sẽ ra
Ừ chị thấy buồn cười phải Dạo này thôi
Bây giờ tôi là số cơ bản nó họ trả lại
thế đúng không cho tạo kênh mới kêu là
bị hack các thứ tư sau đó thì mấy ông
cũng sẽ giờ kênh này chửi nó kính mới
thôi
à à
anh đấy kiếm giỏi do Kia Biển Bố ơi vợ
cần bạn thỉnh thoảng bạn Nhóm II
Ừ ok chém gió thế đủ rồi Hôm nay thì mấy
ông tôi à
Em chưa có một cái ví dụ nào về cái phân
trần nó 3 Mister này à
cho tôi tôi hôm nay mấy ông thấy cái
tiêu đề hôm nay mình sẽ học về à
có thêm sửa xóa Đông Á gì tôi phải ghi
rõ vào mấy cái đấy vì thêm sữa xóa của
mấy thằng này nó khác nhau khác nào cực
giờ tôi sẽ thử ví dụ cho bé ông cụ thể
là cái vụ bài đăng đó ạ
web xin lỗi không ờ
làm tình lang thêm không ạ
khi Apple bây giờ mình phải hỏi lại một
chút họa lại một chút đó là khi nào khi
nào mình làm tính năng thêm
khu ngoại họ khi nào đấy
a location anh nó là số nhiều đấy
anh em thích hỏi giúp tôi nhé
ở
Bình Tân Bình tĩnh cô sao vậy
anh AK
cài thêm bài đăng và khi mà rõ sự giờ có
một bạn hát rồi bạn ấy kiểu inbox cho
mình kiểu dạng là bạn đấy cái inbox cho
mình cái file J để mình thêm nhanh chứ
không phải là
lên trai của mình để thêm trở lại nó ra
sự thế thì mình thêm mày năng mình sẽ
phải làm những cái tiêu chí gì để làm
cái gì nhé
mày mày uống hình dâu ạ nhé bây giờ sự
có bạn HR inbox cho tôi một cái file điạ
Tại tôi có 1 file gì đó nhá Ai có 1 file
đi cả ngày
ở Hà Nội nhé
có một vài người người ta sẽ inbox tôi
một file J giỏ ngay có nhiều phải có
không đầy đủ thông tin như này không có
số điện không có địa chỉ ở đâu đấy nhưng
mà giả sử mới đã gửi tô màu pha như này
đúng không ạ Bây giờ tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ tạo thêm một cái bài đăng thì
nó cần phải lưu lại và những bản nào đấy
để mày ông ấy rung nó sẽ cần lựa thứ
nhất là nó tập lưu vào trong bài năng
thứ hai là nó sẽ lưu chóng phai không ạ
Và kompany nếu có và language mowsi Giả
sử mình cứ Điền trước hết đi mình điện
trước đây nhiều thực là sai nhiều thằng
rất là sai luôn mình sẽ phải sửa lại cái
nhiều này anh sẽ hạn đấy mình tạm xóa
hết cả language đấu bò này trước đã nhá
Ừ
thế giờ mình cần ở đây mình cần làm gì
đấy con em nói bác em đang xài game
server để kệ đi Sách con thời cái là nó
cũng không hả là đúng lắm Mình nói chung
là mấy cái đoạn này ra không phù hợp lắm
đấy nhiều này sách này cái gì đó
anh nói chung là cái đoạn này đang say
rất là nhiều nhưng mà bài đăng này bà
đang cố định rồi nên là tôi nghĩa là tôi
nếu có xóa bằng tay thì nó hơi ạ đăng
bài bằng tay sẽ hơi mất công Đấy hơi mất
công cho những cái bé đang bằng tay à
a través sau phải nhờ mấy ông sữa mấy
ông duyệt các thứ thứ
ở những đại tá như thế đó là tôi có
bạn đấy inbox cho tôi một cái file GP
này tôi làm thế nào để ra được bài đăng
của bạn đấy ông ạ Cũng có cái tiêu đề
kiểu kiểu như này không ạ
Ờ thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ để ý là mình
sẽ cần nhập những gì mình có Urê đi rồi
đúng không Company ID là sửa Company
chưa tồn tại thì sao đấy mình sẽ điền nó
lại đây do tôi yêu cầu mà không phải vẽ
đã vẽ ra cái phom
tí nhá
Có lẽ cái format
tự nhiên mất Di Maria
thế mạnh về quân đội mà không
tại sao nó bảo là mất nói chim
Ừ chắc con nít
ca khúc tôi phải mạnh vẫn ổn mà
hỗ trợ lý xe mà
đi học không lên à
trò chuyện đậu xanh
mất mà
Ừ vợ không biết là có đang phát hay
không nữa alo
à à
đang
Anh đang lái xin nữa
ở bến xe Bình Hòa á Ok có vẻ bị mất kết
nối chat thôi ok không chọn liên tục thì
Ừ thì bây giờ bây giờ cần có cái tiêu đề
không ạ cần có mục tiêu đề để mà
Ừ để mai cậu
anh điền vào tôi
vẫn chưa tìm được cái trang để mà cậu vẽ
cái đấy lắm thích màu xanh này tôi thấy
với cá nhân tôi dùng cái phức tạp không
biết mấy ông dùng có dễ không có dùng
hai kiểu trong phức tạp mãi à
xe ô tô tải ngay
ở Lai Châu
see more Facebook
à à
I stop
à à a12
đợi Hùng tí Tôi đang cố hình dung dẻ
à à
Em không biết dùng cái này nhà luôn
Nhiều người bảo dùng ai dễ lắm
a a a
diện để mà mình hình dung được là mình
cần phải làm những gì tôi bảo hôm trước
đây mình sẽ hết ra hôm trước dùng
grow.io trong nó hơi tệ nè Bây giờ tôi
sẽ dùng cái chao đó thì vẽ là đồ ngoại
mọi chuyện cũng dễ mà dễ mà không thử
nhỉ à
nhỉ
ừ ừ
anh Mạnh tôi hình như đang có vấn đề vậy
khi hát xong rồi nhé
Ừ ông tôi ra mạng điện thoại tôi sạc mua
rồi
Ừ rồi để tôi xem điện thoại nhé à
[âm nhạc]
mà suýt đó Hà Nội đang bị bão ạ
vì tôi nghĩa nó ảnh hưởng cái gì đó
đình đấy
công nghệ thuật
em không lên luôn vãi chưa
hi speed test không lên ảnh
anh em mới đi có lại lên
em hỏi
speedstep giờ mới lên à Vãi chưởng
Ừ thôi tôi sẽ gọi điện thoại vậy à
được cho tôi xem tạm bằng điện thoại nha
Nghe tin ba yêu thật là vừa rồi không
A Pink Tình Ba lùn tốc độ mạng thôi
không Tôi bảo gọi cao nhất của gia đình
mà
với bình thường nha Cái này sẽ là
postgres này
ừ ừ
U17 phút bỏ qua đi
vì tình dốc dow này thế Ngon quá hợp lý
chỉ cần tới ngày rồi nó thì sẽ có là một
cái là đây bản chất là mình sẽ cầm Điền
những cái gì đây mình cần là
ở những cắt điền tên công ty nhà mà nó
sẽ ra cậu đâu như là nó vẫn làm cái đề
xuất rất đau
hi vọng sẽ làm một cái gốc đào nha để
cho mình hoàn toàn thể nhập thêm được
cái gì gì đó em mình sẽ là à không có ni
đúng ạ Company ok chưa Như này hoàn toàn
thêm có thể thêm một cái gì tiếp theo
nữa đó là
nhóm ai khổ cho facial thì ở
a cho các tỉa thường ấy người dùng lại
không nhập hại cho thai thù lắm mà mà
cậu lấy bé ông nghe tôi vẫn đang nghe
đúng không Tôi vẫn đang đọc được tra đấy
Ông ấy ông có gì cứ chat nhé Thì à
Ừ thì người dùng thường hay không nhập
hạn dốc thay thổ lắm ví dụ giả sử ở tôi
về tội chẳng biết nghiệp cho thay đồ là
cái gì mình như là mình sẽ lấy từ một là
lấy từ file này hay đấy từ mình sẽ cho
người dùng Nhập ngôn ngữ vào sau đó thì
sẽ là tên ngôn ngữ tên của công ty Thế
là được đúng nghĩa là cái này nghĩa là
bản chất vẫn có một cái chốt thay thù
nhưng mà ý là nó sẽ tự truyện Noblesse
ra nên tôi xin phép để cuối
em nấu gì Đúng không mấy ông không phải
là hoàn toàn là toàn bộ những cái cột
như thế nào thì ông sẽ theo đúng thứ tự
thế mà ông sẽ phải phải nghĩ rằng là hãy
hãy làm sao cho để người dùng bớt nhập
nhất có thể là được mấy ông Minh không ạ
Đấy tiếp theo là
ở quận Huế thành phố quận ở thành phố là
về cơ bản là mình cũng sẽ phải cho người
dụng chọn thành phố vọng sẽ City đúng
ạ sau đó thì sẽ đề xuất ra những cái
cuộn tương ứng với cái City đấy
đi chích này
à à
ok chưa Đấy tiếp theo nữa là mấy cái này
đều là những cái tích đúng không ạ quý
mốt Apple biến mất Apple Mình lưu lại là
dạng là
nhìn mới dễ nhé
thì tại sao mình lưu lại ba chai này
ti5 ti5 đấy nhỉ
à à
Ừ bia Sài đây anh nói mày nghỉ
mà mình đưa lại đi Này nhá lại tôi nhầm
đấy
khi chúng đúng không nhỉ
Ừ thì một Apple
à mà chỉ cho chọn thường sẽ lấy gót chân
nó bởi nó là cái năm mà
có ai nhà mày đấy à
Bởi vì những cái này nó nó là sẽ ekip
sân nhưng mà về cơ bản nó ít nó ý tiếc
Mấy ông hình trong thì mình có thể để nó
là kiểu dạng là cậu ở tay cực chiếc bóp
bí đao Xem xem hình dung nhé Để tôi hình
dung nhé với mốt Apple cho phép cho phép
là có có thể
ừ ừ
Anh có thể làm từ xa được không đúng ở
mình nhớ như thế nghĩa có hỗ trợ từ say
không mà chỉ làm xa chỉ làm chè Mấy mốt
đây
mày ông nhá remote only ạ và một cái là
remote
em thấy bồ đào nha Chẳng hạn là được
phép ký mốt này một cái là
đó là cho phép hoặc gộp hình
ê ê tố hình dung
Facebook Ly giật sự mình cho là không
có một ngày remote Apple đã cho phép
remote này nó sẽ là 1
phát là
000789 li mốt chỉ remote thì sẽ là không
ạ
vừa cả remote vừa cả là tại nhà ạ ao
nhập với mốt vào làm công ty sẽ là một
này
chỉ là mở công ty sẽ là hai này
khi đó nó sẽ có 3 trạng thái như này có
một cái là
khi chỉ vì một nhóm có một cái remote
con đi chị remote một cái là à
em chỉ làm tại công ty họ là kiểu quốc
only chả ra xử thế ra sự thật không biết
tiếng Anh làm cái này
nghĩa là kiểu nó free Mode chẳng ạ
neutrino đi còn một cái sẽ là
cả hai đúng không ạ và cho phép với một
remote Oppo là
chị đã Candy mốt anh ạ
đề thi thì mình sẽ lưu cái kiểu này vào
và cái này sẽ là cái kiểu dạng là chích
bốc ăn à không phải để xem nhé
lưu lại như này nó sẽ là kiểu một cái là
một cái sẽ là kiểu
bộ kem remote này
A và
Mở camera
đi theo dạng là kiểu có thể làm tại công
ty tiếng Anh rồi nhỉ
bí ngô tổ quốc à dịch thu nhé
em chẳng biết được anh ạ dịch thôi đấy
Nó kiểu như một cái và chiếc box check
vào như này sẽ ra sẽ đã hiểu là
I am fine on site nhở đi ra nước ngoài
mà đúng không bon sai
Anh là gì
em làm việc ngay tại trụ chính trụ sở
ý của khách hàng mà không phải làm tại
công ty bạn nữa Nhầm nhầm nhầm bonsai
không không đúng đâu con trai không phải
đâu
a bonsai là làm tại tải kiểu thường là
làm ở nơi xa làm chỗ
là kiểu tích vào hai cái này nếu không
thích và hai cái này nó sẽ là bưu này nó
là cả hai bao gồm cả hai này bầu này
trên trên cái mốt thôi thì nó sẽ là là
kiểu
anh đào remote ô li Còn nếu không thích
là chị khen go to War và không có tích
và ken ken remote thì tức là không không
cho remote đấy còn nếu thích và cả hai
nó sẽ cả hai người không hiểu không Cái
kem remote này nếu mà ông chỉ thích của
Kenny mốt thì nó sẽ vui Moly này Đấy
can't go to word thôi thì nó sẽ là cái
này và ông thích và cả hai thì nó là hạt
cả hai nấu hình dung không nghĩa nó sẽ
không phải là dai không phải ra ôm Chừng
nào đâu nhá Đấy
chưa cút làm mũi để giao diện thôi béo
ngồi cãi nhau theo
Ừ anh thế nên là đoạn này mày ông sẽ
phải tôi đang hướng dẫn mấy ông kỹ như
này để mà lúc mà Mấy ông nhầm đồ oán mấy
ông phải phân tích mấy cái cái này là
tôi cuối tuần này tôi kiểm tra chỉ ra là
ngày mai đấy mình không phải phân tích
được cụ thể như này theo tôi thì ông học
hãy phân tích được từng cái cái cái form
form này những cái phone này rất quan
trọng ông không nói chuyện là để cho
người dùng nhập hết từ có 20 cột người
dùng nhập đủ và 20 cột sau đó thì cái và
sau đó thì nếu mà ngôn ngữ là công ty
thì sao ông lại bắt người dùng nhảy sang
phòng khác thì nhập công ty cũng cả ngôn
ngữ nó cả file không phải góp hết chung
vào một cá này Bây giờ tôi bảo rồi ví dụ
là sự biết là tôi thêm một cái nghe rồi
để tôi mỗi cái file đúng không Tôi sẽ
phải một lần tôi nhập là phải nhập trong
34 mả tôi không quan tâm người dùng
không quan tâm là có bao nhiêu bà nói
cho người dùng chỉ cần có cái file này
đúng không dùng nhiệt độ là nó lên được
bài đăng của cho người dùng thế là được
đúng không nghe bài toán ở đây là ở
ngoài việc lý rất là nó bảo này mình sẽ
phải đi sớm rồi rất nhiều bạn con nữa
đúng không những bản liên quan nữa đấy
khi mình phải làm nào tiện người dùng
mày dùng bớt gõ chỉ cần tích tích tích
nhận lại được dùng chuột thao tác nhiều
hơn dùng bàn phím là thành công nếu mình
do
ở cây cải trang web của ông mà càng
em tiện cảm dễ dùng là lương ông sẽ càng
cao còn mua khi mà trang web của ông
vượt quá nhiều lần kích quá nhiều phải
điên quá nhiều thứ
Ừ thì chẳng ai muốn dùng cả Đấy phần mềm
thất bại kể cả phần mềm bông có ngon như
nào Tôi không còn tập để phần mềm thất
bại đúng
Ừ cái về chữ ở trên này tôi không biết
sửa nhà tốt cứ tạm hình ai đó thì mấy
ông nhà cân nhắc đó sửa lại cho tôi ngôn
từ tất cả tiếng Anh thương mại Nếu mấy
ông hình dung chỉ thấy không Nó sẽ phải
như thế nó hợp lý nhá Ừ
này cho nó đẹp hơn
Ừ ok rồi nha tiếp là
It's part ham cái này Đây là chứ bóp
thôi à Nó video thôi
à Cậu ôm cái xúc xích này kéo cái này là
kiểu dạng là
À hôm trước đây nhá thì chữ ở đây được
không được anh nhỉ nó ra chữ giờ ở đây
cách
à à
hình ảnh chị sẽ ghi nóng cái chữ ở đây
đúng không là à
chắc là không có trường hợp là công ty
Chị tuyển phát ra rồi nghỉ à
Ừ ok chưa tiếp theo nữa đó là ờ
khi DC cái này phải là đặt tên là phát
âm Abel chung ở tình yêu sửa lại phải
sửa lại tên cột khá nhiều à
mincer imagery
a cho các cái này thì người dùng kích
điện hơn là người dùng kéo người dùng
khó sẵn con số rồi người dùng sẽ copy ở
đây này nếu có thể dùng và người dùng sẽ
copy ở đây hãy hiểu tâm lý người dùng
trong trường hợp này người dùng sẽ copy
cái ở đây chứ không phải là kéo kẹo kéo
luôn kéo đôi khi nó trăm nó bị lệch cái
xong rồi Face phẩy phẩy giờ xấu mày ông
mình trong lòng người dùng sẽ nhập mày
con số thả trong này copy vào sợi thảm
Và như thế này đấy à
khi mình cưới chồng cố hiệu người dùng
hoặc cả mình phải tận mắt chứng kiến
người dùng đã được
22 Plus cái bớt ơi nghe quen quen nhỉ
bớt
Cho Cuộc Tình
Ừ để cải Nam mình
Ừ cái là ờ ờ Office ngoài hợp lý Office
Ok nó còn nó kia sẽ ra hai bớt bầu đúng
không Ok cảm ơn bạn một cái sẽ làm in
solid đúng không I mean sorry
ngay bên cạnh như thế này em mi một cái
mắt được đúng không
đây mình mình sẽ không cho người dùng
bia mà mình cho hẳn cậu mình mình sẽ có
nhập một vài cái
anh kiếm tiền tệ và trong này Đấy mình
sẽ sau đó thì chỉ cần hiển thị ra cho
người dùng xe khách Epson ở đây thôi là
được cái tình tệ nào đó là quần xi
Ừ cái gì này thật sự là đô la này Việt
Nam đồng Xong rồi Alo Sao lại ốm lắm là
tiền Nhật nữa thôi mà chẳng còn đồng là
tiền nó khác đâu đấy còn gì nha
ờ ờ
đi xem
anh
đi qua mình làm một cái cho một cái Tech
rô đây để người dùng nhập kẹo dạng mà
em copy đây nhá Là người dùng kiểu nhập
vào yêu cầu những cái yêu cầu của cái
công việc này nó là gì chẳng hạn thế
Thực ra là có thể đọc từ file nhưng mà
những cái này là những cái quạt
mấy cái này đọc từ file này không ạ
nhưng mà nhưng mà vẫn phải điền mình
mình nên cho người dùng điền vào để làm
gì khi mà khi mà về ông mới ông xin xin
vào ấy nếu không nhìn qua nhìn qua được
Tôi đang muốn làm thuận tiện để cho mấy
ông nhìn được khi mà có một loạt các các
các công việc các thứ thì ông xem luôn
qua được cần trình độ tiếng Anh hay
không cần bằng gì không để mà người ông
đỡ phải click hẳn vào thôi tải file về
phải vào hẳn file xem nếu người dùng
không chữa máy ôm đầu tiên mà ông Peter
hết ở trên rồi nhé Đúng không như vậy
sau đó thì ông đọc Tại sao tôi lại không
cho lưu hẳn vào trong cái khẳng thêm một
cột nữa là cột và yêu cầu bằng cấp 2 là
phải yêu cầu bằng tiếng Anh Cái gì đó về
Rõ ràng mà yêu cầu bằng cấp thì có nhiều
nơi nó có rất nhiều loại bằng mình rất
khó để xác định gì đấy yêu cầu tiếng Anh
thì thực ra là tôi nghĩa tất cả mấy ông
đều nên phải biết tiếng Anh đuổi đọc
hiểu tài liệu rồi trừ khi nó cố tình
phải yêu cầu thêm nếu là sự làm nó công
ty nước ngoài được cầu thêm nhưng mà cái
đấy là tôi thấy à mấy cái mấy cái j đi
của mấy người kia gửi cho tôi không yêu
cầu một cái đấy nè Tôi không cho thêm
cột ở trong này nói cho cái yêu cầu
ngoài thích thì bỏ đi được ngăn chặn cái
này tôi để cho nó luôn mà có thể được
xem luôn cũng trọng tiếp theo ta đến Vậy
em Tết ta Tết and này Thực ra thì mình
sẽ bắt chước cả này bọn mình sẽ copy cái
em heo mập đó thì này
started đúng
ê ê đê Ê
cái And I
apk nghĩa là cái này cũng sẽ cậu không
bắt buộc lắm là cậu số người tham gia
được là bao nhiêu
hình ảnh
một số người nộp là bao nhiêu
em gái cậu như thế này
đi theo tôi nghĩ ngày lại bỏ đi được
mình không có tâm cái này lắm
Ừ thôi kệ vậy Kệ vậy cũng chọn status
này sao Tết này không cho người dùng
Điền sẽ giận rồi à
a pin ở lại không cho người dùng Điền
lắp này là là người dùng có thể điền
nhưng mà mình sẽ kiểm tra thì mình sẽ có
một cái Smart ở đây nhưng mà
Ừ cái này mình sẽ tự sinh ra ngẫu nhiên
hai cái của mình sẽ tự suy ngẫm nghiện
cái chót 2 Thổ này kèm cách lắp mày nó
sẽ tự động sinh tự nhiên Nên tôi sẽ ở
dưới cùng như này này
em
có mấy ông thầy giáo diễn của tôi sẽ như
thế này nghĩa là người dùng hoàn toàn
thể nhập tên Company vào và nó sẽ rớt
trong dat ơi mình nếu có thì gợi ý ra
không thì sẽ là thêm mới city dist thì
mình sẽ không cho người dùng Điền mà sẽ
là sẽ lách góp cho những người dùng chọn
đấy à quên quên ngôn ngữngôn nữa nhỉ
khả năng kích GenK
ID
Ừ đúng rồi
có ai đấy là phải là bài đăng này nó có
những ngôn ngữ gì tôi thiếu đấy
ngữ gì
nhưng mà chọn là dạng số nhiều
Em định sẽ cho nó chọn ở ngay à
ở công ty
a
cho Chọn nó sẽ gần nghị ưu tiên đầu tiên
trong những cái này sẽ language và đây
sẽ là
kỹ năng
Ai biết đâu chính tả đâu nhỉ Lâu lắm
không biết nhé bạn
ừ ừ có về đúng rồi đấy mình sẽ là monty
bồ đây cho chọn số nhiều nha
nhà
gà tre con
anh bita Schneider này mì ông thường
thích làm dụng neither để kéo kẹo kéo
cái này có thể kéo khi mà mình tìm kiếm
con kéo để mà mình nhập vào nó sẽ có thể
bị phẩy phẩy phẩy Nói chung rất là xấu
không không nên thế Mình có thể chỉnh
cái không cho phẩy nhưng mà thực ra
người dùng thấy copy nhập vai vào nhanh
không không không cần làm mấy cái tạp
thế Ok lại phải như này Đây là cái thêm
thêm thôi nhá Cái thêm Còn cái sửa thì
nói khác nhé đừng nghĩ là phom sữa nó sẽ
giống như cái này
những kẻ bị Tôi sẽ bắt đầu làm cái này
nhé Trông cũng Nếu bé uống gì nữa không
ạ Chắc bé ông gì đường quá trông cũng
tương đối cân chỉnh thêm được nghỉ không
chỉnh mày ông có ý kiến gì không cần
phải chỉnh thêm copy diệu không có tôi
sẽ
anh xe ôm đúng cái này về nha
không có cái viền chứng khó chịu ok
Em yêu anh cái này to hơn để to hơn A
cái cái đấy thì không có trọng cái không
trọng
để sao mà em mình sẽ tạo cái form thêm
nữa ngon ông Thế hôm trước đây này thì
Ừ Thì
không Ừ hai cái này cô ấy hai cái này
đúng không quan trọng thì tống xuống
quầy thấy cái à
Ừ Ừ cái này nó sẽ điền nhiều hơn cho
những ngày nay thì hai cái này thì tống
xuống cuối này
Ừ Ok Ok Tôi hiểu không Rồi à
ở đầu tiên thì tôi bảo là bây giờ mình
bạn chất là sẽ hiển thị mình vẫn cho
người dùng Điền nhé Nhưng bản chất là
mình sẽ sẽ cách hay để làm cái này dịch
hai hôm trước Và tôi không biết được và
tôi đã tải về chưa nhiều chưa
lại sợ hay về
này như tôm trước bạc để mình vẫn cho
người dùng nhập anh ta tinh later nha
đấy và đã có thêm một cái mới nha ra
tiện ông ạ Đây mình sẽ mình sẽ chỉ cần
tại về thôi ông ạ Tại về xong rồi thêm
cái này là xong à
cũng được cũng được
mình sẽ hút vào trong này à
tôi sẽ copy cái này nó ngon
có một cái ở đây
quốc gia này ở đây sẽ Linh
em chuyển thêm chén xong ông ạ xong rồi
Tiếp theo mình sẽ có đoạn sweep chất là
mình vẫn lại đó của mình ra đi lại xin
phép sang bên ai gọi cho nhanh ờ ờ
Anh biết mà
à à
em gái mình sẽ có ra đi ở đây
và mình sẽ có
à à
công bị sẽ có ID bằng kompany ạ
Anh thường thường ấy đã Tôi sẽ đặt cái
ID nó selects hơn like công ty mình dễ
hình dung hơn
Em đang dùng hơn mèo nhỏ
và đây sẽ là
thằng select này Tab này đấy
Ừ nhưng mà nó không có một cái ô Chừng
nào đây cả để tớ sẽ cho mấy ông xe giao
diện khi mà thêm sẽ kiểu
áo len mien Nam ngay chỗ qua
An đăng ký Tại sao quét mình qua chỗ cũ
à Nhờ ăn cho lời mình chưa làm gì cả à
ừ ừ
anh lại gọi cho cũng à
cô
dâu tôi rồi
thế âm N cho ngon nút Play
The Flash
bạn này đi không cần Company đây và mình
sẽ dùng api ở đây được Company à
thì mình sẽ call view để xe Air Blade
ngoại ở lại sao ấy
Ừ nó thế giờ mình có thấy à người dùng
hoàn toàn lại điện như này enter này Đấy
một con con đi con thứ không ạ à
anh đấy Xong rồi bây giờ mình sẽ tạm một
cái ivi để mà lấy companies da bạn chất
là nó sẽ công ty ngay
ở
đây
mình sẽ tạo một cái Company controller
đi
hoặc cả thường mà mày ông có thể tạo hẳn
một cái á là api controller được nhưng
mà tôi không thích trong trường hợp này
lắm vì nó sẽ dùng với nhiều chỗ mẹ tôi
sẽ tạo là à company controller
Angela như này
Ừ cái sau đó mình sẽ
à à
ở đây à
đây mình sẽ có là mình sẽ
à à
nhà
đất này mình sẽ
cho tôi quên mất tôi toàn quên đấy đã
nghe mình copy bên tách này nhanh hơn
có gì
anh cứ phải gõ lệnh kiểm
Ơ sao lại đi này không cần view rồi yêu
tinh sau khi tính sau đại đội để company
giờ này
a company
ở Facebook bỏ qua đó mình sẽ public Phan
Xuân ở đây sẽ lại Index và đây mình sẽ
có là data và Đôla zip
sơ đồ sau đó thì em lấy toàn bộ Company
về thực ra Company mình mình sẽ chỉ quan
tâm đến việc là lấy à
xe đẩy ra Ừ nhà Nếu mà người dùng thêm
copy Company mới ở đây về toán nhá phải
dùng thêm Company mới thì
đăng ký up thì toàn bộ những cái này có
thể để chống này Tự Trọng
mình sẽ làm đó là mình dậy xong rồi dùng
nhập cái mới sau đó thì người dùng vẫn
sẽ nhập Vậy à City và đi chích đúng
không sau đó thì mình kiểm tra xem ạ là
à Minh dẫn nhảy sang cái phom nữa Khi mà
giờ sự là cái Company mình không tồn tại
thì mình sẽ bảo là bạn có muốn thêm luôn
thông tin của thông tin của cái công ty
mới này không Mình sẽ hiện ra đúng cái
phom kiểu như thế này cũng được để cho
người dùng Điền nốt toàn bộ những cái
còn lại và sẽ mặc định lấy cái đít và
City mà cái Ford vừa rồi mình điền để mà
truyền ở trong này luôn Nếu hình dung
không truyền trong này a cho nhanh cái
kiểu cậu thế tiện
city của mình có mỗi trong tin của Việt
Nam ơi nhỉ Ừ Ừ chắc là tôi không cho
hiện tại thì chưa có công ty ở nước
ngoài đó
anh tạm thời cứ để để hotcold tại Việt
Nam được
a baby cài theme is often của Digital
city của tôi đang mặc định ở Việt Nam
Ừ cũng được
à à
vợ chồng Zip Code nữa cơ mình phải lấy
Zip Code từ cái City này hôn Ok logo
logo để chống lại cái đấy để cho được
cái Ok
thì à
ở bên mình sẽ duy tân ở đây tôi chỉ em
mấy ông một cái hai ngày nữa nha cái bắt
đầu từ bữa hôm trước và mình đã có cái
vụ là có cái api để trả về thông tin này
như này rồi Ngon Và hôm trước tôi đã chỉ
mấy ông ấy cái vụ là ta truyền thông tin
vào nó có là đã ta như này speak english
như thế này đúng ạ Thì thực tế thực tế
nó là cậu tôi thường hay làm một cái gọi
là cái khái niệm mà chết sẽ tạo ở đây
một cái chết là một cái kiểu dạng nào và
mấy thằng này nó sẽ kế thừa để mà Return
để hay là về nhanh
Ừ tôi sẽ thử Ví dụ ở đây thay vì miếu
cũng phải copy copy cái này liên tục
em không nhớ cái hài có cái kính nước à
à à
a person fast làm đoạn chết đấy cho mấy
ông thấy
hi vọng sẽ Huy dung được cái chết đây
tôi sẽ đặt tên là lephone chết
nói chuyện có tác dụng là để nói về cái
vụ gphone install thôi
ở siêu nhân à p không ạ
ờ ờ
tí cho copy ở Nga này
ông xã ai đi này
Ừ mình ở đây sẽ là osbourne
khi chết ngoạn không kế thừa cái gì cả
thế này sẽ đạt nó là chết như này Chất
hàng ngày nó sẽ là gì mình sẽ có cái hạ
mình sẽ có cái hàm mình sẽ có hai trường
hợp xảy ra đây là khi thành công khi
thất bại thì sẽ là public Phong chân ở
đây sẽ là khi Reborn đ Em sắp xít em ạ
này
em
mặc định ở đây mình sẽ truyền và là data
một cái nữa đó là
mít là
thế này
xe tải vào đây ông sẽ copy cái data này
vào trong đôi ta ngay Miss như thế này
trong mít như này
Em về chưa Cái này sẽ luôn là Chu bác sĩ
sẽ luôn là Chu tại tiếp theo mình sẽ tại
một cái nữa
à à
xấu xí với xanh thả Ok là install trở
lại
Ừ tôi đập đặt cái này ở công ty đặt tên
là gì nhỉ
anh alo sport Chic resort Đại mà ông sẽ
xảy ra tôi sẽ copy kẹo nhà nào ạ
à à
Nhưng cái này sẽ đổi là phone như thế
này bà
chị cũng sẽ có thêm cái á
trăm hiểu là
Anh hiểu là cái cái cái cái
kết quả trở về là nó lỗi đấy nó khác với
cái trên cái trên này mặc định sẽ là 200
nghĩa là trả về thành công Nếu thấy ông
hai trăm nữa thành công con hai anh sẽ
trả 400 kèm theo một cái lỗi kèm theo
cái tin nhắn mình muốn gửi cho người ta
và mình sẽ kế thừa và ngày một cách như
thế này mình sẽ ở đây là ưu nhưng như
này đó
bằng cách là thay mình khai báo kiểu như
này sẽ báo kiểu ở
a Christmas album customers em quên mất
cái đoạn này mình có thể cho status
Custom
400 đi vào đây sẽ là dolce tất và đoạn
này nếu mà không truyền của sao tất và
mặc định sẽ 400 ông thể truyền Giả sử
ông muốn lỗi lỗi về ông muốn lỗi cụ thể
hơn là mã lỗi là gì ông ông muốn ông
muốn thực sự ông muốn biết về các bạn
lỗi hiểm ông tra Google thêm người bạn
anh nhé
Ừ thì nó sẽ rõ 200 thì nó thành công này
còn bốn trăm này nó thường nó lỗi về là
lỗi cho người dùng đấy có lỗi về 500 đổi
cái cái đầu số là năm đấy lỗi do server
cái này ở Liên hoan lỗi do người dùng
thì mình sẽ là đâu bún xong rồi Cụ thể
hơn là suy nghĩ ông cháu Google vào đây
nhé đấy
Ê bà tôi sẽ dùng đây là đô legit như thế
này mà mình sẽ có lá sắc
tôi tôi có tạo phím tắt cái loại này rồi
mà cái tên sắp xít này đó sau đó tôi sẽ
chuyên kể tao tôi vào trong thằng này
đây mày không thấy là tôi có tận hai
thằng data sẽ ở đây sẽ có một mảnh đây
Android cho nó
mạnh đây mình còn data này bằng đôla
data đúng kiểu ngay luôn à
a tiếp theo là tackiness ê
chị sẽ an ninh Đông ạ truyền cái Đôla
và như thế này đúng ơi mặc định mới ship
mình có thể là chấm Chẳng có gì cả cũng
thể cho phép chồng nhé để mình đỡ phải
điền max ít cho xuống không muốn điên
biết gì cả
ngã 3 ông Trịnh Xá Lại đi là sao ạ
mình gọi đến thằng Data là cách biệt
tackiness thì mình phải sẽ phải sửa lại
một tí ở bên A
ở bên flan nhé iPhone em mình sẽ sửa lại
ở đây là cái đoạn là dữ liệu trở về của
mình sẽ là
em restore này respawn ở đây mình sẽ
xe có 2 chỗ iPhone ở đây đúng ạ sẽ chấm
lên data đây nữa
à à
Ừ nó mới chuẩn Ok chưa
ạ Và nếu mà alo Ở đây có một cái lỗi gì
đó thì ông hoàn toàn thể
Em in ra nó đây như thế này
cho ai cần giá
Euro hay xúc xích Alo được mà đúng không
Anh hello nha à
tác giả sự tôi sẽ cho mấy ông in Cái lỗi
ra
a
cerepone chấm music
em thật sự tôi in lỗi chồng để ông xem
nhé Tôi giả sử là ở bên A
ở bên này tôi sẽ
a little
Euro đi cho mấy ông xem cái lỗi gì đó
Tam trường hợp này thì
data đâu thường ở Liên quan max ít nhiều
hơn thì nó không có cho ta ngồi chị gặp
này ta là gà trống
em không có mình không ai điện mới xít ở
trong trại mái hơn sẽ điềm Mission rồi
đây là imparfait được ạ
Ế là xu thế là sự thế à Ê bà
mặc định là lỗi là bốn trăm nhá
cho mấy ông xem qua về cái á
khi FBI kiểu ngày
thôi em khóc em muốn cho phê không có
chuyện truyền data gì cả em bỏ qua bỏ
qua anh à Ừ
hai iPhone to Mac xit của tôi hiểu vừa
rồi sai vậy Đợi tôi tí đợi thì anh ship
khi đồng chí nào nhỉ
chị Hà không lấy được nghỉ à
đổi sang tết đấy
phải lấy từ cái á
sportec
californation sau đó thì mình lấy tiếp
được
ê ê
ở đây là trong trường hợp mà mình muốn
trả về lỗi thì nói như thế còn bây giờ
chả thấy thành công này sẽ ra cái thành
công thôi sẽ hiển thị toàn bộ thông tin
ở đây không ạ Họ vẫn như cũ như cách
viết của mình Nó sẽ thay đổi
để bây giờ toàn bộ những thằng khác của
tôi sẽ kế thừa đúng cái chết mà tôi và
bạn thì sẽ yêu này respond chết thế này
cái à
ạ sau đó thì ở đây mình muốn trả về dữ
liệu đây mình sẽ chỉ cần à đi tập Return
sắp xít ngày rồi chuyển đôla data ở
trong này ra sau đó
ở đây mình sẽ thua là trả về là dạng vi
sinh ở
ở sema class này nha Tôi sẽ gọi đến cái
api kia để trở về toàn cũ toàn bộ
Company đúng không ạ
bên click rồi
em tắt bước đi bên này mình sẽ mình sẽ
dùng uruk để mà gọi lên từ chính nhân
snacks hay là nó hỗ trợ về cái việc là
gọi lên eject để mà để mà lấy lại dữ
liệu ra này mình sẽ có Jack như thế này
lấy dữ liệu ra nha Có thể kéo xuống dưới
cùng nó rất là dài nhá Cái này tùy chỉnh
trong mấy ông vì trình khá nhiều có
nghĩa là đoạn Iraq này nó sẽ chị ngắn
gọn đoạn này thôi này
là chú thích mà bỏ đi đây này
URL là mình có sẵn mua lâu rồi mình sẽ
là sẽ là
router là ăn cái kia thế nhỉ kì ai không
chuyển lên mình để tìm kiếm mình có thể
tìm kiếm nhé Tìm kiếm trở lên cái gì đó
gì đó đây tôi sẽ thì tôi sẽ gọi demo cho
bé ông Tạm thời tạm thời trong đã tạm
thời chạy về hết đã
có quan trọng Đấy cái này là kết quả trở
về của mình ngày cứ cả về này tôi sẽ tí
rồi xin phép và tôi sẽ có cốt trên mạng
về tiếp theo cái này không cần này cái
này cái này tôi sẽ không cần cái này
Custom có thể bỏ qua này ấy chị lại khá
là mình sẽ quan tâm những cái này thôi
Cái quả trở về của mình sẽ cần là
ngay
à à ai cho mày Ông xem cái này quá nhé
anh ấn vào đây
ở đâu nha À cái này cái này chuỗi thì
mình sẽ để nó trong chỗ ích
Ừ đấy Nó đang truyền lên tìm kiếm như
tôi tạm bỏ qua truyền cái tìm kiếm
nhưng mà nó không in ra cái gì đây cho
mấy ông ạ thì tôi thường hay có ở đoạn
này cho nhanh thương tôi thường ai lên
xe câu không ở góc độ này này có bạn
muốn của này
Ừ
đúng cái bạn này là được
à à
về bản chất ở đây mình sẽ cần là mình sẽ
cái tách này là cái mà mình hiển thị ra
và gái đi giá trị thật khi mà chọn thì
thì mình sẽ cần in ra một cái tên rồi
nhỉ một cái lên thôi mà đúng không cái
lên thôi mình sẽ chỉ cần cái này là xong
nữa song nhà
tôi xây thôi Cho miếng Xem này tại trang
này
em mình lại trả về trong cái data thì ra
là mình sẽ phải gọi đến cụ thể là
ở đây sẽ phải chấm Data với từng giá trị
Đà Lạt à
tôi gõ Tìm kiếm ở đây nó vẫn nó muộn mà
nó ra cái này hay nó vẫn đề xuất cái mấy
cái ở đây thì ra là mình mình tiện hơn
mà mình sẽ tìm kiếm hộ trong này thì tốt
không ạ thì ở đây tôi sẽ sửa lại một
chút đó là tôi sẽ truyền the request ở
trong này như thế này sau đó thì mình sẽ
Where mình sẽ thường à Mình quên like
kiểu tìm kiếm gần giống ạ một cái tương
đối ở đó là nêm này xong rồi like này à
Ê mấy ông nhớ like nào thì sẽ có khái
niệm là là phần trăm này nối chuỗi với à
Glass
mình sẽ chuyện à quy lên
thế này cho mọi phần trăm nhé
để trong trường hợp mà cái này nó có một
tí đó là nó thể bị chậm hơn rồi thứ nhất
là dùng phần trăm đến hàng ra là ông
không đánh lên đấy được thứ hai là cái
này nó Nếu giả sử cái này lúc đầu không
không tìm kiếm gì nó là rỗng thì nó vẫn
Tỵ nó vẫn sẽ có que nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là
cái bảng Company mình ít này que nó
không nặng lắm cấp tốc độ nó vẫn còn ảnh
hưởng
ở đây là sự a thế này sẽ chỉ có những
cái Thảo ra thôi cho nó hết đây Ok không
ạ này rất tiện ok chưa tự nhiên mình vẫn
phải nhập inter tinh không ạ Đấy mình
vẫn thể nhập vì nha tinh không sao cả Ok
à
em có language Nam cốc Nhưng mà mình sẽ
là kiểu này vỡ sẽ cho chọn như thế thì
cũng sẽ cho chọn nhưng mà nhưng mà mình
chọn cậu Monte bồ và lần này lại là cố
định không cho nó chọn không cho nó điền
thêm cái mông ích ngoạn mình sẽ ở đây
một cái language này
à à
chị sẽ mình sẽ là
anh em thấy gì đâu
Ừ cái là nó Quốc chạy đúng không Nhưng
mà ở đây mình không cho Điên cái mà đây
đương nhiên là mình sẽ có ý kia để gọi
language rồi ông ạ sẽ language này mình
sẽ có lại bắt chước Hoài đi sẽ có đấy đó
nha Tôi sẽ tạo à
à à
Em hãy mở khi ở mấy ông có chuẩn thì cho
ra mày ông sẽ cốt mấy cái file sau nó
bạn máy phay đầu có và hơn người phải
sau thì copy rồi khác ở nhà tôi nghĩ thế
language
anh như này
Ừ ok rồi này ở đây là language đ
I could find the remarkable Dude
à à
em
đang quét nhà
có tìm kiếm mình có tìm kiếm Đợi tí nhận
lại tí nhé nó biết cũng còn em ok ok Cái
trọng hãy sửa lên mấy ông ạ kia đây rồi
rồi đấy language thôi là xong ở đây còn
này nữa anh biết controller
à à
này Vào đây mình sẽ gọi đến năm
anh
cũng Perry cũng như này có thể thứ không
ạ trả về ai đi học lên ạ nhưng mà À quên
quên quên bình tĩnh Thằng này nó sẽ là
multiple nhớ nhá cho chọn được nhiều
Ừ vợ cha mày
xe tải và mình cho chọn này
Anh Ngọc
anh cũng đã gì đúng không có thể tìm
kiếm
khi họ như này Ok chưa Sau đó mình sẽ
cho chọn Company rồi chọn language các
khu thử đấy A bố tổ ở tí cái Thái Tổ cái
thằng này nó sẽ hơi bị phức tạp một tí
khi mình tự động Jura ra cho mấy cái này
sẽ phải à 1,2 ghi xuống chị nhiều
ý nghĩa Thái Tổ là trung học ở đây do
người dùng đặt Hãy dùng sẽ để sửa sao
Muốn chặn à a tiếp theo ở chọn City với
đi chích thì nhớ không lầm thì giờ tôi
có sẵn cái file
có sẵn cái à
Ừ kệ Vision Một ngày tự động này Tìm lại
City II
mà chết à
xe Vision Việt Nam
một tí có phải Reason to nha
Hà Nội ở Sài Gòn Hà Nội nên mua
kỷ niệm quy xã phường
không
Cho tôi xin phép sandro rồi
quận này ở đây có quận rồi mình sẽ chỉ
cần lấy cuộn thôi mình sẽ có quận quận
này Ok này có vẻ là chuẩn này có phải là
hợp lý tôi sẽ lấy dữ liệu từ ngày mình
có thể hot cốt luôn cái mình sẽ mình sẽ
ôm cái này lưu lại khẳng không cần phải
lưu lại trong bác em mà mình sẽ loa từ
fan để làm đấy thì tôi sẽ copy cái này
à à
hỗ trợ xem nhé cách sử dụng của ngài
hướng dẫn sẽ là
đi xe tải nó về
Ừ ok lưu lại ở hẳn trong thư mục ngoài
đi
em ở đâu nhỉ
đi học tôi nghĩa là lừa destop tôi đi
à à
Ừ tao đói tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ chỉ cần copy cái thứ tôi muốn
thôi
thì mình sẽ có wi-fi này phải quan trọng
này và cả thuốc một ngày nữa hai cái này
tôi sẽ copy cái này số đó và bên này bản
chất là mình cần lấy lấy dữ liệu đấy giờ
tôi chưa Thực tế tôi chưa từng đọc cái á
à
các dữ liệu từ cái lực local bao giờ bèo
tôi sẽ xin phép thuật anh không được thì
thôi ạ Tôi sẽ thử nhé
ờ ờ có phải Index visa này
chị sẽ đổi tên cái này là
ừ ừ
tôi sẽ phải tặng một số mục chuyên làm
mỗi cái vụ này hiểu lý hơn cái này sẽ là
à
a location đi
ở đó cho tôi sẽ mất hai cái ba
đọc từ cái file kia dùng ra Swift phải
đọc từ cái mình cái file kia Translate
ra chữ thủ đâu nhé xin phép thử
Ừ ừ vậy sao
ừ ừ
hợp lý hơn
em về chất hữu hệ thống pháp ừ ừ
a sweet Hạnh nhảy được
nói thẳng kiểu như này đã dùng được cái
biến
à Tôi nghĩ cách này nó cũng hợp lý để
xem nhé đợi xem nhé
ca nhạc à
Hay mình cứ làm cái kiểu bắt chước kiểu
ông kia lắm Được đơn giản đi mình sẽ cho
cái biến này tạo trước là như này cũng
được đúng cách cũng là một cách mà
em ở châu Âu
Em đổi cái này em nó là
có lẽ sẽ là
ô ô check nha Sản mặc cả các bạn này
à à
Ừ đúng nhỉ
cái tôi đổi nón anh ạ
ở tấm
ghép này có
Ừ Ok mình có một pha mình sẽ có là đây
sẽ là ở city
Ê mày cái file cad này bị thừa quá khó
chịu cho iPad
gì đâu With Me ở đây nó sẽ được gì
đó thì khi mà chọn xong rồi nó sẽ loạt
cụ thể để file mình muốn
Chúng tôi sẽ kết hợp cả hai cái đấy cho
mấy ông xe có tiền tôi có đoạn Swift này
đúng không biết ngay Mình sẽ có FLC ở
đây mình sẽ bắt cái file kia ba nhà
chị
sẽ bằng là toptek phát
Vì
sao nói họ để à đâu cái chân rồi à
Ừ nó đi chợ đến file ạ
thông tin tức
khi chấm dứt ở ngoại
đó đi thay của nó sẽ là
cách Spotlight nóng
Ừ thì mình sẽ có cái file kia tôi sẽ thử
con solo chấm lóc ngày cho mấy ông xem
cái Phạn cái thông tin này có ra không
nhá này này là City đây đúng không sẽ
từ ngày thứ ba con được cố định
I speak nha ô tô ở đây nhá Là không có
gì không
hỗ trợ lỗi nhỉ tách ghét cái tí Đợi tí a
tekla skip đúng mà
mà SC Star đường dẫn dài đúng không Đây
đường dẫn có lẽ sai public location ảo
thôi phải gạch chéo một cái lỗi tôi Tại
sao này
Chỉ có mày nghỉ
thứ
hai phải trong nhà nghỉ
thi đấu cao độ nhạy
chuột à
ý nghĩa dùng thường chứ
A2 chấm chẳng lại lót Cái này là dạng
kiểu gì sân nhà ở
Ừ
cái này đấy à
à à
anh biến này Biến toàn cục
ý tưởng thưởng cho trong này nhá
à à
ờ ờ Ok Ok Ok nội tôi tôi không để cái
xong chưa này Bảo sao nó cứ báo lỗi
không biết
lát local
em không được
khi tách nhạc
à à
tôi sẽ sửa lại file này nhà Vision
ở đây tôi sẽ gọi đến cái file đấy bằng
đường link này
khi sex
à à
Galaxy này bạn rất là
soi kèo cái này xử lý bất đồng bộ cái
bản chất này là phải độ gạch lót xong đã
rồi đến được cái này nó xong đã rồi mình
cái này này lại phải đi kiểu này
chợ đồ cổ public
à à
The Flash local find a
chạy trên lô cô ở thằng Anh nó không nó
không mát được thì phải không Không chơi
cái này được
Ừ ok ok lỗi tội lỗi
các đội Asiad được nó nó đã ra được như
này ngon đúng không Mình sẽ đổ cái này
ra
thì mình sẽ đổ cái city rồi ta anh sẽ
City
trong nhà
city.io s
phim hài thằng Hà mình sẽ tạo ra một cái
đít nữa là City ạ City đây
và mình sẽ có truyền ở trong City đấy
sẽ có đô la à
a slack City
39 truyền ở trong đấy sẽ
câu chuyện thằng con vào và những sẽ có
từng góp phần 1 truyền ở trong tháng
ngày mình sẽ là
xừ mất
Để tí nữa xem lại Pháp
Ừ
chừng nào gặp em đi nào nhé
à à
e Sẽ up and ở đây mình sẽ para
ở Hoàng Hà ốc sên
sau đó thì giá trị của thằng này sẽ là
chị sẽ có giá trị của nó
có baru những cả
anh alo sẽ là
Ừ đợi tí nhé
Ừ ừ thế thì tôi nghĩa là không làm kẹo
chanh ở nhà mình sẽ đi kiểu nhà đi
cô giáo option
e-blue bằng đôla x tại đó Tại cốt
đó sau đó thì mình đóng góp chuyện này
mình đóng góp chân à
thứ ngày
vào đây mình sẽ có
ích tại không phải ích tại mà là cái cái
cái cái thằng này Cái thằng này thì nó
sẽ là gì nhỉ Nó sẽ là
khi xe Chuyển kia trong ngày này
nhà sản xuất bạn xem nha
nó là
anh nói xinh mình sẽ
à à
sinh mình phuacs cái thang Vision
the Speed và Speed là phức tạp không tệ
nhưng có dây sân cứ đó rồi
Đợi mình tí để mình tính nhé
sẽ có Inax Blue City truyền nào
hỗ trợ thông tí đại lý tôi Ẩn Ẩn 2 đĩa
tôi thử con solo chấm gót Jack và value
trong bé uống xem đã
rồi thằng baru tức a chứ thằng ích đấy
như thằng này nó đâm sẽ ẩn mình sẽ cái
này là Index nó sẽ ghi ta
chưa chị nào chị nào nó gãy rồi nhưng mà
mình cũng sẽ phải cho thằng salad này
ngay từ đầu nó sẽ ra sẽ rất hay nhá thì
sẽ cho nó là salad hay như này để cho
người dùng có thể nhập tìm kiếm Để gì đó
ai Nếu để xem nhé
Chị nào
Ừ nó tiếp theo cái khó hơn đó là bây giờ
mình sẽ
I wish I passed cái này cho em tôi xuống
dòng Tại sao tôi sẽ muốn làm đi nhé cho
nó nhìn cho nó đẹp không tí
dòng đoạn này thôi sẽ thêm thì ở trong
này sẽ có data ở đây kết phát rồi Nãy
bóng để kỹ Ở đây có khái niệm về cái
Pháp là cái đường dẫn khi mà mình chọn
cái Hà Nội này bản chất là mình sẽ Note
cái cái á quận của cái Hà Nội đông ạ thì
mình sẽ là lợi ích tại hát hướng dẫn hơn
nãy sau đó Khi mà mình chọn cái Hà Nội
các bạn chắc là mình sẽ flash cái khác
này để để mình sẽ có cái gọi đi chích ở
đây mày Ông nhé ạ cuộn
Em hôm nay làm có cái giờ không làm kịp
cho sửa đâu rồi cái thêm lại đã phức tạp
phải không ạ Thấy không không dễ đâu ngờ
cái này thì tôi nghĩ mày ông cũng kia
đúng ạ cũng hiểu nó sẽ đó đi Khi mà mình
Bây giờ mình bắt bài toán là khi mà mình
thay đổi kìa Khi mình có tiên mình vẫn
phải loát cái đầu tiên đã gần như là tôi
nghĩa sẽ mặc định nói cái đầu tiên
city Hồ Chí Minh đầu tiên không ạ Chị sẽ
loa cải cuộn đầu tiên đã ngoạn sau đó
thì
ở quận của của thành phố đầu tiên sau đó
đi bất kỳ khi cái này đổi thì mình sẽ
bắt đấy cái pass của nó để mình lại phải
loạn cái á
đoạt cái thằng à kia không ạ
Lý Hải
thằng này đầu tiên đã thì tôi sẽ tạm một
cái file trên ở đây ở Los đi chích ngay
cho dễ hình dung I
Em làm ở đây mình sẽ cần là mình sẽ cần
lấy cái thằng City đang được chọn mình
sẽ là Peru như này là mình sẽ đẩy cái
thằng mà nó Sơn đây City cái thằng đang
được chọn mình sẽ
nhớ không lầm và cách viết nó sẽ là như
này nhá có cách mẹo viết của ông là mấy
ông có thể chơi là xe Lexus này à
nó
không xem nhé
Bạn ấy chích tôi sẽ chạy sau khi mà cái
này được đổ ra xong nhưng mà đương nhiên
là phải phối ngày nó chạy như này rõ
ràng là là thằng này chưa chạy sao này
đã chạy rồi là không quan tâm thì rõ pet
hoài tôi nghĩ đến tốc độ Open này kể
quen thằng đầu tiên vẫn nhanh hơn nghe
vẫn được ở nhà
xem à
sẽ tất bằng sức à
Thuê xe mà ghét sẽ thật Ocean valley
0.3.3 lấy cái
bộ truyện sex
đ.to
mở đây loa lại được
à Tôi nghĩ ako chấm chấm tách có về gần
đúng có phải là đúng thôi sẽ Black
element
ông Trần xe tất
anh
hoặc là nó chưa kịp loát tôi Nghĩa thằng
City chưa kịp Lost thằng này đã lót rồi
rõ ràng à bắt xong rồi mà không lấy được
cái đã tạm phát ở đây là có vấn đề
hoặc cả tôi lót này trước ạ Em thử đã
ở đây đây đây Đúng rồi không đã phải gọi
để thằng không sau đó thì mới
vợ chồng data Pháp lại đông dẫn
à À rồi
ở đó đi
à à
ông Trần đeo 1
thằng Tài chứ nhỉ
nghe nó ra An defy lỗi tội lỗi tội lỗi
tôi hát này có vấn đề
nụ cười thật sao mình không ra sẽ
đội ích ở đây mình sẽ con solo chấm
a doctor RX Xem cụ thể
I gotta này đúng rồi phát đúng rồi tự
nhiên bảo Sao vừa nãy chụp ăn refine nó
lại cậu ra dạng khác
cho iPad đổi tội lỗi tôi nếu để ý thì ăn
đi file tự nhiên nó màu trắng này bình
thường nó sẽ mẫu màu ghi tức làm chị
không tìm thấy còn đây là nó đúng à Nó
biến hình chuỗi
mình sẽ loát cái bát cái đấy tiếp thôi
Chị sẽ bát xong rồi tống vào sẽ thoát
cái cái file cad ấy ở trong này
thì
mình sẽ wi-fi Pad ở đây này không ạ
A là
Ừ cái file này sau đó thì mình sẽ
phải khiến cho xin này trước nha à
a
cho mình sẽ có đề đi chích không ạ đi
chích
có ai sôi Lát vào select này
sẽ tạm ẩn cái thằng này đi
thằng ích đã xem thực sự là cái là đi
chích này nó là gì
à à
Vì sao con sơ đồ lót ở đâu đấy nhỉ
em đợi đi
khi mua cá lóc rồi mà thằng ích này đang
bị à
Ừ đợi tí xe mà
chứng tỏ ra thằng là cái thằng file này
có vấn đề
Ừ ai cũng đề đấy xem thử Sài Gòn nhé
kênh của mộng được
anh tặng pha lỗi đi
mình sẽ bỏ qua hai cái này mà mình sẽ
chọn thằng này đi chút mà mới cho
ai chấm Đi chết đây à
ở đâu rồi ạ
có tỷ lệ tình
thì tại sao nè
ở đó ok chưa ngon chưa mà mình sẽ quan
tâm đến cài quận thôi đúng không ạ
ở những cái nào là quy là cuộn Bỏ qua
những cái huyện ạ sẽ là ít
acts chấm free E bằng bằng bạc bà dao
bằng sắc của
mình sẽ lấy I
ông ngoại dễ truyền vào trong cái đấy
chuyện ở chồng đi chết này à
hình ảnh sau đó đi với thằng Cuội thì
mình sẽ có mình sẽ lấy tên của nó thôi
sẽ là ích chấm nêm
Độ Tội Lỗi
Ừ thế thì ở đây mình cứ điều lại thẳng
tên ba lô thẳng tên con rể Mã Ô thế
không không cần baro thẳng ngại đổi được
này mình sẽ là không cần ba lô này sẽ là
ích chấm
nên
là không cần đào tạo phát gì à lại ngắn
gọn súc tích ngay à
à Xong rồi thử nghỉ tại trang này
Ừ nó ok chưa chọn chọn cá thứ chứ nhìn
nhá nghỉ nhé
Ở bệnh viện không bác lại rồi tôi đã làm
gì đấy Bây giờ trong trường hợp mà khi
mà chọn cái này xong thì mình sẽ thoát
lại cái this này
ở nhà xe này
thì mình sẽ gọi thẳng điện thoại
à à
em gọi được kiểu nhà em nhỉ
Á hự pháp nhà không
có ngon không vào được chỗ này à
phải làm kiểu thủ công rồi móng chân này
bạn gì hết này
nghĩa là khi mà chọn thành phố xong mình
sẽ đoán lại cuộn
Ừ nếu mà mỗi khi đó lại quận thì mình
đồng nghĩa việc là mình phải xóa cuộn cũ
đi đấy Xóa toàn bộ những cái á quận quận
cũ đi Chị sẽ là sẽ là như thế này
bộ remote vi mô là xóa luôn cả ngày nhé
em thì tôi không nhớ là cái gì lắm Nhớ
em đi được
Ừ dạo này đó ngon không chịu đâu
khi
chọn quận Cam này là chọn thành phố cái
này ra cuộn ngon chưa
Tôi tự nhiên thấy tôi chuyên nghiệp cái
vụ này
xét hai nữa
à Thế cho có thể
này có nhiều điểm nhá có những điểm nhá
Tân Bình ngay đúng không lần này
anh mất luôn ở Tân Bình rồi
Em
ở đó Ngoại hồi trước tôi bị cái là nó
còn vẫn còn lưu lại cái giá trị cũ có vẻ
Bây giờ chạy được ngon hơn ổi tra nó sửa
lại cái thư viện của xét hay nghe khi
mua mất hẳn rồi Ok Thế đùa em béo thấy
sĩ nào giờ thì mất công một tiếng 50 mấy
phút kiểu ngồi làm mỗi kiểu chọn thành
phố với quận hết xơ thời gian
Nhờ cái này mấy ông thì ông là gần như
là tôi cái cách của tôi làm nó sẽ là
Coffee có trên mạng và cái này có thêm
nhiều điểm nữa đó là mấy ông nhìn kỹ cái
HTML của mình rất là ngắn chỉ có muốn 30
dòng nhưng mà ra suýt nữa là dài đấy là
nhược điểm của về sau đó là giáo dục ít
và rất là dài để nó sẽ nó sẽ sinh ra hết
tiền đó để cho trang lót nhanh các kiểu
tự nhưng mà nhưng mà hại máy người dùng
máy này dùng sẽ là một lát rồi Đúng ra
Speed này để mà chạy bạn muốn làm cái
dùng cái việc là đấy Cái gj cốt nó cho
vợ chồng nó cứ xấu xấu như thế này về
sau rất khó sửa rất khó cải tiến về sau
thì ông theo Facebook thì cốt của gia
quyến và ông vẫn dài thôi nên chẳng qua
về sau dãy sửa cốt thằng really công
nhận trong nó xấu nhỉ không thấy cho
chúng Xấu mà lại tôi không khẳng định
đẹp rồi xấu
tủ lạnh tivi trong cứ đều đều đều màu
màu Thái cứ
ở trong số 6 kiểu gì ấy nhỉ
em chấp nhận nhận bé học à
a tiếp theo nhỉ Mẹ chưa xong tôi thấy
thời gian đó lực có hạn nữa
ở Tam Quốc nó dễ sửa không hề dễ sửa cái
đấy tôi khẳng định Em gốc ở sinh ra để
dễ sửa sẽ chỉnh sửa còn really về cô bạn
nó thư viện nó không phải làm cái thứ dễ
sửa
checkbox trong ạ
chú ý nghĩa là có khi là bộ Hôm nay chắc
chỉ cần tạm mấy ai thôi mấy cái mấy cái
đang ăng dậy rồi này thì buổi sau tôi sẽ
tiếp tục hát hay sao có mày tạm Hôm nay
tôi nghĩa là hơi quá Tại cho mấy ông rồi
nha Mày thấy có tài chứ
Ê mày chả tặng ngừng đến đâu rồi nhỉ Còn
mấy cái kia thì ạ buổi sau tôi sẽ chữa
tiếp Insert so với các tựa thử chứ hôm
nay tôi bị không Để xong thì với việc
hoài dẫn ngay nho mấy ông cũng hình dung
được hôm nay tạo nhiều file flash rồi
cũng làm mấy việc ở ikea thay đổi kết
hợp việc là
làm chết này xong rồi con À load file
của local như nào không ạ xong rồi lấy
thư viện ở trên mạng về xử lý như thế
nào có giữ thứ bài toán bài toán mấy ông
hình dung cách xử lý và toán đã trở
thành công thôi ông ạ ở các bộ mày tạm
thế này nhỉ
cho em hỏi làm ta Switch cũng thời gian
mãi tôi là PT mấy ông thấy tôi nhảy sang
tay làm bên nhanh không Sang bên này
ngồi sữa rất ít mất thời gian thật mà
thời gian cứ ngồi Kiểu kiểu phải nó
Block ga rồi cảm thấy từ tốn rất nhiều
thời gian mỗi các loại rau Quý à
em bỏ mày chả tắm tạm ngưng ở đây đã
thì nó sẽ đầy cốt này lên làm anh em xem
tham khảo nữa phẩm chứa anh em có thể ạ
kéo cốc này về thôi chỉnh sửa gì đó xem
hiểu được không kéo cốc này về chạy được
đấy ạ Em chạy được không đấy rồi tính
tiếp nha
Anh Ngọc A
Xin chào béo người còn mỗi hai ông đang
xem ai Ông ngoại toái rồi
thế nhá